for most of this week you've been using
a encoder/decoder architecture full
machine translation one RNN reads in a
sentence and then different one outputs
a sentence there's a modification to
this called the attention model that
makes all this work much better
the attention algorithm the attention
idea has been one of the most
influential ideas in deep learning let's
take a look at how that works so get a
very long french sentence like this what
we are asking this green and coda neural
network to do is to read in the whole
sentence and then memorize the whole
sentence and store it in the activations
conveyed here and then for the purple
Network the decoding network to then
generate the English translation Jane
went to Africa last September enjoy the
culture many wonderful people she came
by raven but how wonderful trip wasn't
tempting we need to go to now the way a
human translator would translate the
sentence is not to first read the whole
French sentence and then memorize the
whole thing and then regurgitate an
English sentence from scratch instead
what a human translator would do is read
the first part of it maybe generate part
of the translation you know look at the
second part generate a few more words
look at a few more words generate a few
more words and so on
you kind of work part by part through
the sentence because it's just really
difficult to memorize the whole long
sentence like that and so what you see
for the encoder/decoder architecture
above is that it works quite well for
short sentences so my achievement
relatively high blue score but for very
long sentences maybe longer than 30 or
40 words you know the performance comes
down so the the blue score might look
like this as the sentence length varies
and short sentences are just hard to
translate how to get all the words right
and long sentences it doesn't do well on
because it's just difficult together in
your network to memorize a super long
sentence so in this and the next video
you see the attention model which
translates maybe a bit more like
humans might looking at part of a
sentence at a time and with an attention
model machine translation systems
performance can look like this because
by working one part of a sentence at a
time you don't see this huge dip which
is really measuring the ability of a
neural network to memorize a long
sentence which maybe isn't what we most
badly need in your own network to do so
in this video I want to just give you
some intuition about how attention works
and then we'll flesh out the details in
the next video the attention model was
due to zoomy tree bother new Kemper
intro and Yoshi Avenger and even though
it was originally developed for machine
translation is spread to many other
application areas as well and this is
really a very influential very seminal
paper in the deep learning literature
so let's illustrate this with a short
sentence even though these ideas were
maybe developed more for long sentences
but it'll be easier to illustrate these
ideas of a simpler example we have our
usual sentence jane visit murphy console
tom and let's say that we use a RNN and
in this case i'm going to use a
bi-directional RNN in order to compute
some set of features for each of the
input words and here i've drawn the
standard by there's the RNN with outputs
y 1 y 2 y 3 and so on up to y 5 but
we're not doing a word-for-word
translation so let me get rid of the Y's
on top but using a bi-directional RNN
what we're done is for each of the words
or really for each of the five positions
in the sentence you can compute a very
rich set of features about the words in
the sentence and maybe surrounding words
in every position now let's go ahead and
generate the English translation we're
going to use another RNN to generate the
English translation so you know here's
my RNN node as usual and instead of
using a
to denote the activation in order to
avoid confusion with the activations
down here I'm just going to use a
different notation I'm going to use s to
denote the hidden state in this RN and
up here and so instead of writing a 1
I'm going to write s 1 and so we hope in
this model that the first word that
generates will be Jane right to generate
Jane visits Africa in September now the
question is when you're trying to
generate this first word this output
what part of the input French sentence
should you be looking at seems like you
should be looking primarily at this
first word maybe in a few other words
close behind but you don't need to be
looking way at the end of the sentence
so what the attention model would be
computing is a set of attention weights
and we're going to use alpha 1 1 to
denote when you're generating the first
words how much should you be paying
attention to this first piece of
information here and then we'll also
come up with a second
that's called attention wait alpha 1 2
which tells us while we're trying to
compute the first word hopefully Jane
how much attention how much the tension
to repaint to this second word from the
input and so on and alpha 1 3 and so on
and together this will tell us what is
exactly the context come to know the
seat that we should be paying attention
to and that is input to this RN and unit
2 then try to generate the first word so
that's one step of the RNN there will
fashion allow these details in the next
video for the second step of this RNN
we're going to have a new hidden state
s2 and we're going to have a new set of
attention weights so we're going to have
alpha 2 1 to tell us when we're
generating this
I guess this would be visits maybe
without being the grantee label how much
should be paying attention to the first
word in the French input and also alpha
to 2 and so on how much should be paying
attention to the word visits how much
should I pay attention to their freak
and so on and of course the first one
regenerator Jane is also an infant to
this and it read some context they were
paying attention to the second step
there's also an input and that together
will generate the second word and that
leads us to the third step s Li this is
an input and we have some new context
see that depends on you know the various
alpha me for the different time steps it
tells us how much should we be paying
attention to the different words from
the input French sentence and so on so
some things I haven't specified yet but
that will go further into detail in the
next video is how exactly this context
defined and the goal of the context is
for the third word is to really should
capture that maybe you should be looking
around this part of the sentence and in
the formula you used to do that will
defer to the next video as well as how
do you compute these attention weights
and you see in the next video that alpha
VT which is when you're trying to
generate the third word they're supposed
to be Africa just getting the right
output the amount that this RNN step
should be paying attention to the French
word that time T that depends on the
activations of the bi-directional RNN at
time T so it goes so depend on the
foreign activations and the backward
activations at time T and it will depend
on the state from the previous step so
it depends on s2 and these things
together will influence how much you pay
attention to a specific word than the
input French sentence but we'll fetch
all these details in the next
but the key intuition to take away is
that this way the RNN marches forward
generating one word at a time until
eventually it generates the EOS and at
every step there are these attention
ways alpha TT prime that tells it when
they're trying to generate the teeth
English word how much should you be
paying attention to the T prime French
word and this allows it on every time
step to look only maybe within a local
window of the French sentence that pay
attention to when generating a specific
English word so I hope this video
conveyed some intuition about the
attention model and then you now have a
rough sense of maybe how the algorithm
works let's go onto the next video to
flesh out the details of the attention
model